plane and it's going to be a multi-plat
I I just I find it hard to believe this
game would be successful I mean um my
father's order was successful I agree
because that's the thing it's just all
of a sudden so what all in order was
successful yeah it was
it's not I I understand what kings
called I was there
because of course thank you well today
there's another key statement that kings
are like basically they said um they
talk about the powers a lot they said
the thinking there was that more people
have played Apex Legends than have even
heard of tight before so they were
really going to lean into that no you're
right I understand where you're going so
you said it's their fault it's their
fault okay
at that point
if more people's playing Apex Legends
and those characters are beloved by all
these people why would a game with those
characters not do well
um
[Music]